[Music]
you sure you can lift this much weight
are you kidding me i was the strongest
kid in my camp seven summers in a row
it would have been eight if that freak
rebecca lobelman hadn't showed up
let's put in work and here we go
one and i'm done that's it oh good rep
don't wanna get too bulky i can see that
you're upset but let's just sit down and
talk about it
done talking time to dance
fine but i should warn you i took three
years of tap
sarge it's so good to see you uh just
out of curiosity how did you find out
about this
i'm a detective sergeant in the nypd
ho told me why are you cutting me out of
operation what that's crazy
boyle come in here and stand in front of
my body and tell them that's crazy
ow my lucky face you gonna talk to me
now uh
sure uh if you could be any vacation oh
you didn't let me finish if you could be
any vacation
what would you be i'd be skiing oh no
i'm gonna hit you for real that wasn't
for real oh my god
no wait wait wait i was worried worried
about what about you getting hurt
i don't want your daughters growing up
without a dad i know what that's like
and it sucks and i don't want it to
happen to them
why didn't you say something to me
because i didn't want to get in your
head and have you freak out again
you know i get it it's been a rough year
but i've learned to embrace my fears it
makes me a better cop attacks one and
two are set 30 minutes until the bogeys
arrive thanks boyle
i love it when you say bogeys
so we good we good oh
for the record if i could be any kind of
vacation
i'd be late trip classic
hey my arms don't work can you scratch
my nose you bet mm-hmm
yeah thank you okay i got your favorite
cake
blue i'm not hungry it's a figure of
speech
obviously i'll have some yeah come on
man use your muscles
use my muscles oh great why didn't i
think of that
great advice terry you know what it's a
pull-up there's not much to coach here
okay how is you doing that helping me
[Music]
good job can you do it without screaming
pro
bub lee then we're ready do you still
know how to ride
come on riding a bike it's like riding a
bike
wheelie no boy no well it's cause you're
watching okay
one more try one more try one more try
one more try one more try did you do it
okay you guys know the course
first one to get to creston and tenth
rides for me loser is out
hey body you seem like a reasonable dude
just let me win and i'll owe you big
time i really need this i really need
this too
i've been eating in three days and my
bookie says if i don't pay him back he's
gonna kill my dog
okay that's very intense please let me
win since my mom died that dog's my only
family i am so sorry i shouldn't have
engaged got way too real i'm gonna lose
everything yep putting on my helmet
now ready go
sorry about your dog oh man why did i
say that now i feel terrible
i'm gonna win i'm gonna win rip rip
[Music]
oh i see what i did wrong i did the jump
back
you okay jake well aside from the fact
that the 99's hearing is in four hours
and we're definitely getting shut down
no i bruised my thigh it's gonna be just
fine jake no
it isn't charles it's on my right hip i
sleep on that side
i'm stupid of me to think i can make
this the best case ever let's just go
back to the precinct so you can make me
hot coco
i can't believe i'm gonna say this but
no i will not make you hot cocoa
charles i have a bruise sniper
binoculars here charles tell me how far
away i am
too close to measure they really work
that's everything let's do this
this is way too much stuff yeah and it's
too heavy to carry all the way back
terry where is this guy
deal was supposed to go down 10 minutes
ago stupid criminals have no respect for
the people trying to bust them yeah i
really wish he'd show up i got to go to
the bathroom so bad
it's like a third time today man what is
going on with you oh amy freaked out
cause i told her i never drink water so
now she's making me drink eight glasses
a day
it's like there's water and soda there's
water and coffee there's little pools of
water on pizza that's grease jake well
it's wet isn't it
come on i'll buy you a drink that
doesn't have any pills in it sounds good
but i wish you hadn't mentioned liquids
now i have to pee
i promise you i will never drink water
ever again oh thank god it's the worst
brb
hey terry you get my email
about how i was coming down here no i
haven't checked my phone
ah no need i just wanted to make sure
you're here you know you know how i like
to have a weight mate
really i have never seen you in the gym
what
i basically live here i'm a regular jim
dandy
besides i gotta get into shape for all
the godfathering i'm gonna do i mean how
am i gonna throw our baby up into the
air with these noodle arms
good point so take me through your
workout man rip me up
you know let's rip it out time to rip it
down
those aren't gym terms and i don't think
you can handle my workout oh wow
sounds like a challenge to me come on
give it here
i gotcha ready yep oh my god come on
push it
push it yeah five
oh man this is almost too easy are you
crying
no that's eyeball sweat all right let's
wrap this up
i gotta call sharon and get back to work
no no no hey i thought you said
this was gonna be a challenge huh it's
been a cakewalk so far
oh you want me to make this harder yes
that is what i want more harder exercise
look sarge
i burned 200 calories that's your heart
rate yeah that checks out
come on jake ten more minutes
i think we should stop now peralta no no
i'm still good
check this out right hook right hook
the uppercut my arms
don't seem to be responding to my brain
anymore come on jake let's go
so how much blood do you usually have in
your mouth when you do this
no
great i'm done great workout sarge
now i believe i owe you a thousand
push-ups i don't care about the push-ups
jake
i care that you didn't honor our pack
i've always trusted you and when you did
that it made me feel like you don't
trust me
i know and i'm sorry it won't happen
again no it won't
now go down on the floor what you just
said you didn't care about the push-ups
i changed my mind
fair enough
back's packed
one two three
612. night peralta
[Music]
613. hey ronald
oh 1 000
is so many push-ups i'm never gonna make
it
what am i at 901 thank you captain
i said 2 000 remember
you